Uh thank you Tony for the very kind
introduction and uh thank you for
joining me today. And the topic I'm
going to introduce today is uh how we're
going to use generative model for data
assimilation task in our subsurface flow
system. Uh so before oops yeah so before
um I'm going to dive into some technical
detail I want to motivate the research a
little bit. I know this is a very broad
community on the datadriven modeling uh
but my domain is specifically on
subsurface flow. So why we want to study
subsurface? Uh subsurface is very
important for providing different type
of resources. uh for example
approximately 80% of US energy and 40%
of water come from subsurface and there
are many many uh important applications
uh on the energy sides uh we have the
hydrocarbon uh geothermal and for our
net zero energy future we need to store
carbon in the deep subsurface we also
want to get groundwater from subsurface
and also many other including like a
critical mineral uh natural hazard
investigation for the subsurface system.
So one of the key question we want to
work on for the subsurface system is we
want to understand and also predict what
happens in the large scale system. So um
it's quite straightforward when we want
to understand and predict we need to do
modeling and uh here I'm using the flow
model simulation as an example. Uh we
started from the geological parameters,
geological models as our input and we
solve the numerical simulations for
multiase flow in porous media and get
the dynamic states like say pressure
saturation for the whole reservoir and
uh the example for the equation is we
solve the diversity flow process. We saw
the mass conservation and uh uh the
numerical simulation for subsurface flow
is actually quite challenging because we
need to consider very complicated
geological models and we need to model
the nonlinear dynamics. Uh it's often a
multiscale uh from poor scale to field
scale and also a multifysics problem. uh
we have a flow problem, we have thermal
uh chemical uh mechanical problem for
the whole system. And another more
challenging issue is we don't actually
really have all these informations on
the equations and the parameters uh
subsurface is very deep is a unseen word
to us. So when we do all these forward
simulation, forward modeling, we want to
have a full understanding of all these
rock properties. Uh here I'm presenting
one example of a layer system with a
font in the middle. Uh so we can see uh
the color is different everywhere, which
means the raw property is different
everywhere. Uh so that's basically what
we want for numerical simulation. But
what we actually have is just very
limited experiment near the well for
subsurface because we need to drill the
well to like thousands of meters. These
wells are generally very expensive. We
can only do experiment around the well.
So most of the area are kind of unknown
to us. We have lots of question mark and
uh nowadays we have lots of monitoring
techniques but all this information are
kind of incomplete. Um we may have like
the borehole data we may have geoysical
or remote sensing data but these data
generally are indirect sparse and very
expensive.
So the uncertainty is a big issue for
subsurface is kind of a inherent
problem. Um so with all these question
mark when we do the modeling we first
develop our geological model. uh here
I'm using a gausian model as an example
uh where we have a different guess prior
gas of what's the geological model look
like and here I'm presenting three
different realizations and then we
conduct numerical simulation on that to
get the dynamic states and here I'm
using CO2 injection as an example on the
right is basically the CO2 saturation we
can see with different geological models
because the CO2 goes in very different
ways. Uh the size, the shape, the
orientation, they are all different. So,
uh extensive monitoring with data
assimilation is kind of essential for us
uh to quantify and then further reduce
the uncertainty uh in our domain or I
also refer the data assimilation as
history matching. So, uh in general, how
do we do that for subsurface flow? um we
use Bashian's uh framework or we use BA
Bashian framework to solve this problem.
So uh which means we start from ensemble
of prior models. We may have like a
thousands millions of gas was a
geological model look like and we
conduct numerical simulation to get all
these prior data as show in the gray
curve. It shows a saturation change with
time. So we have multiple realizations.
We can see quite a large uncertainty of
that. And after we collect observation
data as show in all the red dots, uh we
can kind of use data simulation basian
inversion to calibrate our geological
models to match all these observations
and further conduct numerical simulation
to generate the posterior prediction as
show in the blue curve. And then we can
achieve the uncertainty reduction goal
and we can also get a better
understanding a better inference of the
geological model. And uh so let's put it
into the basia framework. So basically
the posterior distribution uh is
generated from the prior distribution
and the likelihood and then we use
numerical simulation to get our
posterior predictions of the dynamic
state. This process is still quite
challenging as many other science and
engineering task uh because first we
need to calibrate very complicated
geological models. uh here I'm showing a
example of a fracture and 40 system we
have been collaborating with Chevron
years ago and uh it's a really high
dimensional non-galion system if we want
to calibrate all these fractures and uh
the following task is since we want to
uncertain quantification we generally
need iterative simulation runs to get
the distribution of no matter prior or
posterior. So uh generative model these
days actually provide us opportunities
to generate all this distribution. Uh
the idea of generative model is we want
to learn the target distribution from
the training data and generate new
samples from the learn distribution. Uh
so two uh very kind of a standard
example these days for computer vision
is we can generate image from gausian
noise uh different dog image cat image
and we can also generate image videos
from different prompts from different
text uh here we can generate uh leaf and
with different orientations.
uh but um how we're going to use it for
our more serious scientific question is
uh generates the conditional posterior
probability of the model parameters and
then uh further predicts our future. So
uh the generative image is can be used
for our prior distribution in the
framework. It can help us generate the
model and also generates the data. And
another use similar to the generate
image from task from text is generating
the uh posterior distribution condition
on some guidance on some observations.
So the goal of this talk is uh we want
to apply generative model to conduct a
very efficient subsurface data
simulation and uh I will introduce three
recent work on how we are going to use
generative model to generate prior uh
prior of geological model or prior of
the uh dynamic states for direct
forecasting and in the end I will
introduce a unified framework for a joy
inference of both the model parameter
and the state variables. So let's look
at the first task on how are we going to
generate the geological models. Uh so
the case study I'm going to use here is
for inhouse geothermal system. uh
in-house geothermal is very important
these days because it provide us uh
renewable and reliable energy resources.
Uh so the idea of inhouse geothermal is
we want to uh inject cold water into our
deep subsurface. We want to create a
fracture in the subsurface uh uh
basically to have the high permeability
pathways to extracts the heat from the
deep rock and uh to produce the hot
water from the subsurface system. So uh
the fracture really matters fracture
network really matters in the inhouse
geothermal system it's kind of control
the flow and thermal behaviors but there
still exist significant uncertainties uh
here I'm presenting to different
fracture network and after we do
simulation we can see the temperature
distribution can be very different so
the goal of the first task is convey
generate different fracture network and
then further calibrate this fracture
network condition on the observation we
have. Um so back to the BA framework um
the first task is we want to generate
the fracture network and once we have
the fracture network the likelihood is
actually easy to calculate. we can apply
numerical simulation on that and
calculate the data mismatch and then get
the likelihood. Once we get the prior
get the likelihood then we can get the
posterior. So for the prior generation
uh the framework we use is the latent
diffusion framework to generate the new
fracture network that follow the same
distribution as in our training data.
So uh a little bit detail on this latent
diffusion uh model. So the first step is
we want to map the original fracture
network into a latent space using
variational autoenccoder. So why we want
to do everything in the lat space? Uh
because for subsurface flow uh when we
want to infer the fracture geometry we
may have thousands of fractures. Each
fracture we need at least like four uh
parameter to quantify the location, the
orientation and the size and then we may
have like a lot thousands to millions of
parameters we need to calibrate. Uh it's
going to have the curse of
dimensionality problem. So uh the first
is we basically want to parameterize the
geological model and map it into the
latent space. then it's going to be easy
for us to sample and to calibrate. So we
use wee to map it into the lat space. So
the idea of a is we want to reconstruct
the fracture and also at the same time
we add some k diverges to uh make sure
the latent is approximately gausian and
uh uh the second component of the latent
diffusion model is we use uh the
diffusion model. So uh the idea of the
diffusion model is a very popular
architecture these days. The idea of it
is we have the forward noising process.
We gradually adding noise into that and
to make it follow gian distribution by
the and after multiple steps and uh then
we want to generate new realization we
use dising um process to basically get
rid of all this noise. So uh we train an
unit in the den noising process to learn
basically the noise and to help us
generate the fracture realizations. Uh
so after we have this latent diffusion
model we can combine that into our data
assimilation framework. Uh we start from
the gausian distributed latent variable.
We apply the uh latent diffusion model
to generate new fracture realizations.
We conduct numerical simulation to get
all different dynamic states and once
the observation come in we can calibrate
these latent variables to get the post
zero prediction for the dynamic states.
So the latent variable basically are
updated for the whole framework. And
then some of the model uh modeling
techniques we use is uh for the
parameterization we use latent diffusion
model and for numerical simulation we
use embedded discrete fracture models uh
to basically modeling the coupled flow
and the thermal process. And then for
the data assimilation we use ensemble
smoother based method. Uh what we use is
ensemble smoother with multiple data
simulation. Uh the idea is we calculate
the mismatch we use the coarus and the
information gain to update our latent
variable and once we get our posterior
latent variable and we can further use
the latent diffusion model and the EDFM
to get our posterior predictions. Uh so
let's look at the case study we have.
I'm not going to presenting all these
details but basically what we want to
work on is a 2D DF framework. Um here we
specify we want to generate 20 fracture
in total. We want to tune the fracture
network to actually match the
observation we have. And uh for the
training data we use power law
distribution to generate all these
fractures. And uh uh then we conduct
numerical simulation on that. Uh since
the main uh target for this project is
we want to know the geometry, we set all
the other parameter to be homogeneous.
Uh we inject cold water into the system
and we produce hot water and we compare
two data simulation setup. So one is we
have one monitor at producer and the
other is we have additional four
monitors in the middle for this field.
Um and we want to u measure the data
using the tracer and the temperature
measurement from the first few years and
to predict what's going to happen in the
future. So first let's look at what's
the generative model give us. It give us
the prior distribution the fracture
network. The first row shows the
training samples the MRST realization we
use and the second row shows the LDM
generative realization. So um I would
say the fracture generation is actually
very challenging task uh because the
fracture is very thin but LDM still
doing a very good job to generate. we
can clearly see the fractures and also
see the connection of the fractures and
then we do some uh fracture statistics.
Uh we use a method called a
probabilistic half transform to detect
the fracture line and then we calculate
the statistics and comp uh compare with
the training. Uh so we uh check the
fracture list the angle the midpoint
location it all looks good. Um the a
little bit issue with the number of
fracture since in this case we specify
we only want to have 20 fractures but no
matter for the training image or for the
generated image they don't capture the
fracture very well it's kind of related
to the way we are using for the fracture
detection but I would say overall it
still provide a very promising fracture
realization and we further validate with
our flow statistics
uh we conduct numerical simulation onset
to get the 10% 50% and 90% of the flow
statistics for temperature and for the
uh tracer and we can still see like in
the prior with a lot of uncertainty and
uh the generative result is kind of have
a very good match with our training
simulation runs
and then we further use it for our data
assimilation task. So we have two set of
uh uh monitoring data. The first uh the
the first uh uh column is the result. We
use one monitor. Um I would say the
fracture geometry calibration is a very
challenging task. So even though we have
some observation, it's still really hard
to give us enough information to capture
what a fracture look like. But when we
get more and more data here like say
five monitor in total uh we observe
significant uncertainty reduction as
show in all the blue curve compare the
gray shaded area as our prior. So uh
this give us a um strong signal that um
in this case we may need more
observation data in the future. And uh a
little bit on the fracture network
tuning and we can see the true we have
very clear fracture geometry the network
and the connectivity. And if we look at
the mean of the prior we basically see
nothing. And when we have one monitor,
it shows a pattern a little bit, but
still not much information. And then
when we check the posterior with five
monitors, it's kind of give us a clearer
pattern, especially near the producer.
So for this case, um one main challenge
for the uh subsurface task is the
geological model can be really
complicated. The geometry sometimes can
be really hard to tune to calibrate and
we need lots of observations.
So that's one of the application of
generative model for what we call the
very traditional model based inversion.
We want to infer the uh geometry. We
want to infer the geological model and
then run simulation to get our posterior
predictions.
The challenges still remain like say for
this case if we have thousands of
geological realism the generative model
may have difficulty to generate all
these fractures and uh also sometime we
may have lot of unknown uncertainty
source for the model inversion only if
we know what parameter we want to tune
we can tune that but what if so this
system we have many many unknown and uh
uncertainties resource from um multiple
parameters. How are we going to deal
with that? So a complement framework
what we developed for years is called a
data space inversion. So the idea is we
want to directly use our observations to
predict the future. We just want to skip
and avoid all this model calibration. Uh
so let's come to the second topic. How
are we going to use generative model in
this data space inversion for a direct
forecasting?
So uh back to the bashian framework when
we want to generate the post zero
prediction of our future condition on
observation we still need likelihood and
we still need prior distribution. But
let's look at first what we have in our
data vector D. So it's basically
includes two component. The first is the
monitoring data. We have pressure
saturation stream data and the second
component is the future we want to
predict. It's not only the dynamic
states of the current step but more or
less on the future after 10 20 50 years.
So we put some of the forecast in our
data vector and then once we put
everything in the data vector the
calculation of likelihood is also quite
straightforward. We just need a
extraction matrix to get the observation
from it. And then um the task is gonna
just transform it to be how do we
generate the prior distribution of the
whole uh spatial temper data and uh
since we consider the spatial temper
data for very large scale 3D system
parameterization is still very
important. we want to conduct everything
still in the latent space. So by
parameterization uh we want to map the
highdimensional non-gausian spatial
temporal dynamics into our latent
variable low dimension and gausian
distribution and uh also ideally we hope
the generator can preserve all these
dynamics all these physics into the
generated data. So this is a um very
simple illustration. We want to start
from the steel gausian noise use
generator to generate the spatial
distribution for different time step and
uh then in that case once we have
observations we can directly extract
from the full data vector D and use it
for calibration. uh so we have been
working on the whole idea for years and
we have lots of different architecture
uh here I'm going to present youing one
architecture we used recently for the
spatial temper for the 3D spatial temper
distribution and uh the input is we have
a time series of all these spatial
distribution and we apply the encoder um
which is a 3D convolutional LSTM to map
it in the latent variable and uh then
the decoder is applied on the latent
variable uh to map it back to
reconstruct the original spatial
temporal distribution. And uh the
adversary part is we add a discriminator
to basically force everything to be gion
in the latent space then which enable us
to do the direct sampling. And after we
have this generative model, we can use
the decoder as the generator when we do
the calibration. And we can further
transfer the conditions probability of
data vector to the condition posterior
probability of our latent variables. And
uh then we combine uh we still use ESMDA
here to generate the post theory
distribution but we can also couple that
uh with like say MCMC more time
consuming more rigorous algorithm since
the decoder part is super fast we can
achieve everything just in second
and uh let's look at the case study we
have for this data space inversion
The application we use is a geological
carbon storage. Uh the idea of
geological carbon storage is we want to
inject CO2 into deep subsurface thousand
of meters. We want to permanently store
all this CO2 in subsurface. So after we
inject the CO2 question we actually want
to answer for the reservoir scale is
first we want to confirm the
performance. We want to see what's where
the CO2 goes after the injection. We
want to see how much is the pressure
gonna increase for the whole system. And
the second is there might be some
potential risk associated with a CO2
injection uh cause poor pressure
increase going to trigger earthquake if
in the 40 system. So we also want to
know like what's the uh probability of
any uh induced seasmicity. So uh in this
case uh we are going to introduce two
case study. The first is we use
horizontal injection for a 3D system. Um
we have four injector rails and eight
monitors. I'm not going to introduce all
the details for the setup but one thing
I want to mention is for this geological
model uh we consider the uncertainty
from two source. First is we consider
multiple geological scenarios which
means uh we kind of parameterize use
some global parameters like say the mean
the standard deviation of permeability
parocity correlationless and anisotropic
angles. So these are the global
parameters which define the geological
scenarios and uh at the same time we
also consider the hydrogenarity of the
distribution which means the spatial
distribution for every single
realization is different. So with the
traditional data assimilation task uh
this type of task is generally very
difficult to uh calibrate. uh we usually
use some hierarchical architecture to
first find the best scenario and then
further um tune the hydrogenerity the
geological model but with the data space
inversion framework we don't actually
care about all these parameters we just
work based on the data we want to use
our history to predict our future so uh
the result for this application is um we
and observe the CO2 saturation after 20
years. The first row shows the prior
realization. Uh we select everything
using uh clustering and uh select the
representative samples and uh the bottom
shows the true result of the saturation.
We can see basically based on the prior
u none of the realization looks like the
true realization. But after we apply the
generative model and data space
inversion for the post theory in the
middle um all of the five of them they
show very clear pattern of the
orientation and they show equivalent
size of the CO2 plume. We observe
significant uncertainty reduction for
the size and the shape
and we also calculate some quantity of
interest. For example, we are interested
in the average saturation for different
layer. We are interested in the average
pressure and uh if we use the generative
model to just generate the prior as show
in the gray area still lots of
uncertainty but after applying the
calibration data space inversion we
observe significant uncertainty
reduction for that. And uh uh one thing
I want to mention a little bit is if we
do everything using numerical simulation
um every simulation take five minutes we
need to run like more than 1,000
simulations. So one data simulation task
may take days but when we use generative
model directly work on the data. So once
we finish the training process, the
inferris is going to only happen in four
minutes with one GPU. It's basically
super fast. And since we have all this
special temporal distribution in this
data space, it's also very flexible in
monitoring location and the arrow setup.
So which means every time when we want
to change monitor, we just modify the
extraction matrix. we don't need to
rerun all the simulation again and again
to calibrate the models and generate
posterior predictions.
So another case is for the 3D port
system with couple flow and geom
mechanics and uh in that case we
consider two fort in the 3D system we
want to see we have three injector in
the middle after we inject the CO2 was
the response of the sleep tendency for
this fort and uh we also consider um m
multiple geological scenario here uh for
example for the four properties. Um we
change the uh permeability multiplier,
we change the young modulus pose ratio
and we also consider the spatial
distribution for all these matrix. Um
and we generate 1,000 realization to
train this generative model in total. So
uh for this DSI task, what we want to
know is just the sleep tendency of this
fort. So the observation we use is a
pressure stream data from the floor
monitors near the floor and near the
injectors and uh we use generative model
to generate the prior distribution of
pressure strain uh effective normal
stress shear stress together and after
we get all these quantities we can
predict the foot slip tendency.
So uh similar observations for our post
theory result uh for prior loss of
uncertainty and after we apply DSI uh
the post theory we see very clear
pattern very close to our true
observations and uh in this case since
we consider a couple flow and geom
mechanics problem the computational cost
is higher is one hour compared with five
minutes before and uh by using DSI
everything can be done in four minutes.
So it saves us a lot of time if we want
to change the monitoring location or any
of the measurement arrow setup. And uh
similar for the sheer stress for the
prior loss of uncertainty and for the
post area we can observe a very clear
uncertainty reduction for it. And then
uh we calculate the quantity of interest
for our task. Um uh we use the ratio
between the uh share stress with the
effective normal stress and we compare
we calculate the uh mean value of that
we compare it with our prior we still
observe significant uncertainty
reduction on the sleep tendency.
So um with the generative model we can
efficiently generate the prior of the
geological model and also prior of all
these datas. So can we actually combine
everything together to uh have a unified
framework to do a joint inference of the
geological models and the state
variables using generative model. So
um how are we going to generate the
posterior distribution directly based on
our observations
and and the idea is still um I do like
the latent data assimilation idea. So
for the joint model and data space we
want basically have multiple encoder and
decoder to map everything in the latent
space and then we add additional layer
to kind of capture the nonlinear
correlation between the model and the
dynamic state and then we only need to
work on the latent space using
generative model. It can save us a lot
of time on something the large domain
and also the encoder decoder net setup
can help us capture all these
correlations and then once we have the
latent space we apply the scorebased
diffusion model to map the latent space
into gausian space. So for the forward
diffusion similar to the latent
diffusion before uh we gradually adding
noise and we use the forward stoastic
differential equations and then for the
sampling process we use the uh reverse
SD to get rid of all these noise and to
generate the joint geological model and
data variables. So uh one very important
component for the reverse SDE is the
score function. So basically here it's
learn the prior and uh we're just going
to use the gausian noise with the learn
prior to generate the original
highdimensional distribution and then if
we don't do any conditioning it's just
similar as the latent diffusion for
previously for the geological model and
how are we going to use it to directly
generate the conditional probability. Uh
the key idea is we combine the Bashian
framework with the score function. Uh we
just add the likelihoods into the term
and since in this case we have all this
data variable in the uh input space. So
basically when we do the observation
generation we can directly extract it
from the input space and uh it's
differentiable it's good and we can
directly calculate the posterior score
function and then use it to instruct us
to do the posterior something. So with
this framework, we still test it for a
geological carbon storage task. And in
this case, we have one injector in the
middle and we first set four monitors
around the injector. And we also
consider a case what if we have like the
whole saturation map uh illustrated from
some 4D seesmic data. What's the effect
of more measurements can provide us?
So let's first look at the posterior
data with the prior data. Here the gray
shaded arrow still presents the P 10%
90% of the prior generated by the
diffusion very large uncertainty and uh
after we provide some guidance using our
observation data and using the
likelihood we can clearly observe the
uncertainty reduction the posterior are
show in all these black curve as uh have
a much smaller uncertainty compared to
the prior. And uh so that's just the on
the left is just the data from four
monitors and on the right if we can have
the whole map more sees data. So we can
further constrain give us uh strong
constraint and strong guidance on uh
what's the posterior what's data should
look like in the future and uh uh we
also use it to predict the posterior
saturation after 30 years. Uh here is
the spatial distribution. Um the first
row uh is the top layer. So this is a 3D
model. I kind of um use different layer
and different cross-section to show the
result. And on the left is the true
distribution. We can clearly see the
pattern of the CO2 plume. And if we
check the prior mean, so we basically
don't see anything. We don't see the
pattern. And after we have uh four
monitors uh we calibrate the uh future
prediction a little bit and the mean is
kind of a look more like the true
response we should have. And if when we
have more and more seesmic data we have
the spatial distribution we can further
calibrate give us a more reliable
posterior predictions. is looks much
more like the uh true response and so
that's for the data part and uh at the
same time it can also uh generate all
these model parameters uh simultaneously
and uh in this case we assume is gausian
distribution uh on the left is still the
true result and uh um we can first guess
the prior mean and since this is gausian
basically
Um the property everywhere is just the
same. And when we have one monitor since
the monitor are very close to the
injector, we only observe the
uncertainty reduction in the middle of
the whole region and also like near the
injectors. So uh for example like in the
middle we kind of see a little bit of
the pattern of the permeability
distribution but after we get more and
more observations
uh we can further calibrate it and then
now we have a clearer pattern of the
permeability distribution no matter from
the uh top layer of from the excess
crosssections. So um this results kind
of demonstrate the power of generative
model for us to directly do um condition
uh generating of the post serial
probabilities and we can generate the
model parameter generates a dynamic data
simultaneously. We don't need to have
any simulation runs even though these
days we may have lots of s modeling it
may help but this method is still enable
us to um generate everything together
and capture the correlation of all these
stuff. So uh so um let me uh summarize
the uh project I introduced today. So uh
we first consider to use generative
model to generate just the prior
distribution. Uh we see the geological
model the fracture network and we also
see the application for the state
variables and once we get the prior we
can calculate the likelihood either from
simulation or from um the extraction
matrix and we use it for data
assimilation. And the second is uh we
develop a unifi framework to use latent
scorebased diffusion to jointly update
the parameters and also the future
predictions. So um while reflection for
the subsurface domain is uh since
subsurface is very deep getting
observation is really hard. So we
generally only have like one point or
only several point of direct observation
of dynamic states. So one important task
is is also what we are doing now is uh
we want to incorporate multimodel
observations
um not only the incitual well
measurements but also a lot of the
indirect geohysical survey remote
sensing data to use it to further
constrain our model and to further
calibrate our understanding. And uh
another extension we are working on is
sys either DSI or with a latence or base
diffusion. It's very efficient. It can
be directly used for the monitoring plan
optimization. We can calculate the
information gain based on all these
realistic case uh to find the best
location to put our expensive sensors.
So um a little bit high level uh
introduction on the research my team is
working on these days. So uh the
generative model and data simulation is
only one component of the big picture.
The goal is eventually we want to use AI
to revolutionizing the subsurface flow
modeling study. We want to use it to
have real time predictions on certainty
quantification and decision making for
different earth environmental and energy
systems. So um one of the idea is we
want to have digital twins for different
subsurface system and uh it's kind of
built on the traditional what we call
the closed loop management. We have
monitoring, we have operation, we
collect the data, we do modeling, we do
data assimilation and then we make
decision. Um and then using the decision
is further guiding us to uh do the next
step action. And uh so my plan or what
my group is doing is we are trying to
integrate the physics and AI in this
very traditional closed loop management
process to get a very efficient
management for um lots of subsurface
system and uh yeah in the end I want to
uh acknowledge and thank the student and
also my PhD advisor and also CMU for
providing all this computational
resource.
Yeah, that's basically all of my talk
today. Uh, thank you. Thank you for
joining me and I'm open to questions.
>> Thanks for the wonderful talk. Uh, it's
very inspiring and interesting. So, now
is the Q&A section. Uh, if the audience
you have a question, please feel free to
unmute yourself or raise your hand.
Okay. Um while we wait for the audience
for their inputs, I myself have several
questions out of my curiosity.
So uh I'll probably start with uh
something on page 19 about uh the
generation of the discrete fracture
models.
>> Yeah, page 19.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. as you as you mentioned like
making sure all these decoded images are
looking like the description models are
are difficult. I can totally understand
that.
>> Yeah.
>> But uh I want I'm I'm wondering uh the
unconditional generation sometimes
actually non-physical and nonrealistic
say they are blurred or broken. Do you
see that in your
Okay. So can you come on like do uh any
specific techniques to like picking
kinds of uh more realistic generations
to to start with your uh in your like
the UK process or uh making the whole
model generate better images at all?
>> Yeah, this is a very important area. We
are also considering to have some
improvement because we can clearly
observe some like broken fracture here.
And uh uh one strategy we are
considering is uh the fracture network
is not just like visually the image we
need to use it for the following
simulation. So we are trying to combine
with the simulation input because for
simulation when we do the embedded
fracture we need the uh distance of the
fracture uh to the center of the grid we
also need the orientation of that and
then it's provide us lots of
implementation on like what the fracture
should look like. So we are trying to
see whether we can add some additional
parameters not just only like say this
that image into this training process
and uh we we are also trying to see
whether we can introduce some additional
loss for the geometry informed because
we know if everything is on one fracture
then the orientation should be the same
the angle should be the same. So one uh
thing I'm we are considering is can we
add some loss into that to have some
soft constraint on that. Uh so um
another issue for the fracture
generation is probably the 30,000 may
not be enough. We may need like more
samples since it's quite challenging. We
need to capture all these edge very
clear and uh we may also want to do some
like refinements or postprocessing based
on these fractures. Yeah, thanks for the
question.
>> Yeah, sounds good. Uh so Joseph uh
please take your question.
>> Hi. Yeah, thanks for the talk. Um I'm
wondering so in in your results towards
the end it looks like
the results might be a little bit biased
maybe towards the prior. So I'm
wondering if
>> you've maybe tried like updating the
prior with the posterior and then doing
some sort of iteration and
>> you know if you tried it like does it
work and if not why not?
>> Uhhuh. Uh are you referring like say the
geometry or like overall the comparison
of for example we have some uh uh like
say here the prior very different but
for the posterior.
>> Yeah. Yeah. For example those. Yeah.
>> Uh yeah. So um yeah let me use let me
see if I have that.
Yeah, I should probably have some like a
prior and posterior. Yeah, for example,
uh like say here when we do the prior
assumption, so we kind of make it a very
broad assumption have a very a lot of
uncertainty. So when we do the synthetic
case when we select the true model is
kind of fall in the prior assumption we
have. Uh so currently even though it may
look like the post theory is very
different from the prior but it's still
always in the same assumption. So that's
kind of one thing and the other thing is
uh we actually have similar work if the
two model is kind of biased. It's really
outside of the prior distribution. We
also have some techniques to instruct
how are we gonna modify our prior. We
want to redesign our prior and we often
call that type has the model error. So
we want to design a new prior that it
may have a better understanding. So um
that's also like the results the data
simulation can give us not only just the
posterior prediction but also some of
the indication instructions for the
future prior calibration.
Yeah thanks. Yeah that's a very good
question. Yeah. Um yeah, I I do think we
have one paper um back to probably years
ago on investigating the treatment of
model error. Well, um in the data
simulation process
um
any more questions from the audience?
Um I can actually ask one more. So on
maybe on page 33
uh
>> oh yeah so yeah this this results looks
very promising and f fantastic but I
want to make sure if I'm understanding
correctly that the say the multi motive
phase flow physics loss is actually not
incorporated in the likelihood and the
posterior in the generation
um it has not been incorporated yet. So
we just use the observation to calculate
the likelihood. So I would say for now
all the methods are purely datadriven.
We don't have any like PD residuals or
physics loss into that.
>> I see. Yeah. It was a concern for me
because seems like it it might give up
some guarantee of physics cont
consistency but yeah it's great.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So that's also something we are
planning for the scorebased diffusion
because when we design the score
function we can add the likelihood from
observation but at the same time we can
also add some physics constra as a
guidance when we generate the post
theory. So prior probably not
necessarily you follow oh prior we can
still add set but we just don't have all
these observation that's just the other
term u for the score function design
>> yeah and ultimately do you plan to
incorporate like different levels of
data I I think you have like a the
history I mean the lo history and the
seismic data so like make it a whole
integrated framework.
Yeah, that's what we are currently
working on. So, um sesmic data is a
little bit different because um for all
these state data, we can directly use it
from the data vector but sesmic data is
generally like indirect data. So, we
still need to basically connect our
either geological model or dynamic state
to the sesmic data like say the
velocity.
Yeah, I see.
Yeah, thanks for the answers. Um, so are
there more questions from the audience?
So, if not, let's thank you again for
her awesome research. Um, yeah, thanks
for the wonderful talk.